Katrina: 你拿两个那个
Katrina: You take two of those.
Shure: 什么
Shure: What?
Shure: 来
Shure: Come on.
Tasha: 我觉得这个不粘吧
Tasha: I think this doesn't stick, right?
Jake:这就是线吗
Jake: Is this the thread?
Tasha: 应该吧
Tasha: I think so.
Shure: 疼就是说明有毛病
Shure: If it hurts, it means something's wrong.
Shure: 怎么不舒服呢
Shure: Why does it feel uncomfortable?
Jake:噢对就是破防
Jake: Oh right, it's a vulnerability.
Jake:你就被他破防了
Jake: You've been made vulnerable by him.
Shure: 你又怎么
Shure: What about you?
Jake:他去买了个药
Jake: He went to buy medicine.
Jake:然后你拿了药他说他有
Jake: Then you took the medicine and he said he had it.
Jake:就是这样
Jake: That's it.
其他人：就这样补什么药啊
Others: So, what medicine?
Shure: 什么药啊
Shure: What medicine?
Tasha: 感冒药呀
Tasha: Cold medicine.
Shure: 他怎么还感冒了呢
Shure: How did he catch a cold?
Jake:他感冒了呀
Jake: He caught a cold.
Tasha: 他
Tasha: He...
Shure: 是啊怎么这么脆弱呢
Shure: Yeah, why is he so fragile?
Tasha: 就是呗
Tasha: Exactly.
Jake:有顺序吗
Jake: Is there an order to it?
Shure: 你别传染给我吧
Shure: Don't infect me.
Tasha: 不知道呀没有吧
Tasha: I don't know, probably not.
Shure: 你快回学校吧你
Shure: You should hurry back to school.
Jake:哎哈喽
Jake: Hey, hello.
Jake:哈喽啊
Jake: Hello there.
Shure: 你们好
Shure: Hi, everyone.
其他人：放哪
Others: Where should we put this?
Shure: 麦克风拿来了吧
Shure: You brought the microphone, right?
其他人：拿了拿了
Others: Yes, yes.
其他人：这连个架子都没有
Others: There's not even a stand.
其他人：你要怎么弹
Others: How are you going to play it?
Shure: what the敢拿的吗
Shure: What the... can you even take it?
其他人：就趴地上弹
Others: Just play it on the floor.
其他人：放在桌子上弹
Others: Play it on the table.
Jake:有电有电
Jake: There's power, there's power.
Jake:这边有电
Jake: There's power here.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
其他人：放哪你说
Others: Where do you want it?
Jake:哦好嘞
Jake: Oh, okay.
Shure: 这放二楼吧
Shure: Let's put it on the second floor.
Shure: 到时候咱都在二楼
Shure: We'll all be on the second floor later.
Tasha: 怎么样哪个好看
Tasha: What do you think? Which one looks better?
Shure: 这不是我们宿舍那小推车吗
Shure: Isn't that the little cart from our dorm?
其他人：对啊对啊
Others: Yeah, yeah.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
其他人：线条小狗
Others: Little doggy.
其他人：就在这晒
Others: Just let it dry here.
其他人：晒足180天
Others: Let it dry for 180 days.
Shure: 好厨邦酱油美味鲜是吧
Shure: So it's the delicious Chef Bang soy sauce, right?
其他人：晒足180天
Others: Let it dry for 180 days.
Shure: 在2楼吧
Shure: On the second floor.
Shure: 我感觉
Shure: I think...
Shure: 我感
Shure: I feel...
其他人：把饮料放在二楼调
Others: Let's put the drinks on the second floor.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Shure: 我觉得放在2楼会好一点
Shure: I think putting it on the second floor would be better.
其他人：对
Others: Yes.
其他人：卧槽买打火机
Others: Damn, buy a lighter.
其他人：厨房就是没有啊打火机应该在厨房
Others: The kitchen doesn't have one. A lighter should be in the kitchen.
其他人：哦我懂你的意思了不能带有女生的
其他人：牛逼
Others: Awesome.
Shure: 吓我一跳
Shure: You scared me.
其他人：今天不昨天更好吃
Others: Today’s food is better than yesterday.
其他人：今天只有昨天剩的好吃
Others: Today, only yesterday’s leftovers taste good.
Shure: 今天
Shure: Today.
其他人：一楼还有一个汉堡
Others: There’s a burger left on the first floor.
Shure: 来把这个清理一下他
Shure: Come on, clean this up.
Katrina: 这个桌面是干嘛来着
Katrina: What’s this table for?
其他人：这桌面是放琴
Others: This table is for putting the piano.
Shure: 行放琴吧
Shure: Alright, let’s put the piano there.
Shure: DJ台懂吗
Shure: You know the DJ booth, right?
其他人：好用的一逼
Others: It’s super useful.
Shure: tasha your电脑
Shure: Tasha, your computer.
Shure: 知道了
Shure: Got it.
Katrina: 怎么在头上啊
Katrina: Why is it on your head?
Shure: 先先放我把这收拾一下
Shure: First, let me tidy this up.
Shure: 你们再放
Shure: Then you can put it there.
其他人：这是你的琴吗
Others: Is this your piano?
Shure: 他的
Shure: It’s his.
其他人：卧槽你呃你搁宿舍的
Others: Whoa, you brought it from the dorm?
Shure: 我们来把我们的超级无敌KTV
Shure: Let’s set up our super awesome KTV.
Shure: 搭建起来好吧
Shure: Let’s build it up, alright?
Shure: 把这桌先收拾下去
Shure: Clear this table first.
Shure: 我这地好黏
Shure: The floor is so sticky.
其他人：踏板
Others: Pedal.
其他人：我试试踏板好用吗
Others: Let me try if the pedal works.
其他人：肯定好用
Others: It definitely works.
其他人：我操太垃圾了
Others: Damn, it’s so bad.
Shure: 哎呀
Shure: Oh, man.
其他人：这你踩啥踏板
Others: What are you stepping on the pedal for?
Jake:牛啊
Jake: Impressive.
其他人：我什么时候踩踏板了
Others: When did I step on the pedal?
Shure: 对这才是那味
Shure: Yeah, that’s the right vibe.
Shure: 我们在收拾这个桌子
Shure: We’re cleaning up this table.
Shure: 你又往这点放
Shure: You keep putting stuff here.
Jake:我往这里面放
Jake: I’m putting it here.
Jake:往床上往地上放
Jake: On the bed, on the floor.
Shure: 菊次郎没有熬过的夏天
Shure: A summer that Jūzō never endured.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
其他人：菊次郎365天都在过的夏天
Others: Jūzō’s summer lasts 365 days.
Katrina: 还有垃圾往这里扔吗
Katrina: Still throwing trash here?
Shure: 这谁的
Shure: Whose is this?
Shure: 这是什么
Shure: What is this?
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Whoa
其他人：给你找个凳子
Others: Let's find you a chair
Shure: 这应该不能吃了吧
Shure: This probably can't be eaten, right?
Jake:给你来个土耳其进行曲太难了
Jake: Playing Turkish March for you is too hard
Shure: 这真的是土耳其的吗
Shure: Is this really Turkish?
Jake:创作歌手
Jake: Singer-songwriter
Shure: 你的土耳其
Shure: Your Turkish
Shure: 我的土耳其
Shure: My Turkish
Shure: 好像不一样是吧
Shure: Seems different, right?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：你的土耳其我的土耳其好像不一样
Others: Your Turkish and my Turkish seem different
Shure: 卧槽
Shure: Whoa
Shure: 你这土耳其真的跟我们的很很不一样
Shure: Your Turkish is really quite different from ours
Jake:你土耳其在打仗啊
Jake: Your Turkish is at war
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: Jazz版土耳其是吧
Shure: Jazz version of Turkish, right?
其他人：这些这些都需要收了吗
Others: Do all these need to be packed?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes
Shure: 你辅助一下他吧
Shure: Can you assist him?
Shure: 啊卧槽
Shure: Whoa
Shure: 这到时候视频就是
Shure: So this video will be
Shure: 哎我哔
Shure: Oh beep
其他人：吃多了已经
Others: Ate too much already
Tasha: 吃破方了已经
Tasha: Ate too much already
Shure: 那我就不用给你买了
Shure: Then I don't need to buy it for you
Shure: 雅
Shure: Yeah
Jake:我的线在哪啊
Jake: Where's my cable?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:给他印俩眼睛呗
Jake: Print him two eyes
Jake:你的线呢
Jake: Where's your cable?
Tasha: 我的线在楼下
Tasha: My cable is downstairs
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Tasha: 刚看了
Tasha: Just saw it
Shure: 这小扇是谁的呀
Shure: Whose little fan is this?
Tasha: 在椅子上我的
Tasha: On the chair, it's mine
Tasha: 你会咬扇子吗
Tasha: Do you bite fans?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure: 哈哈来一个
Shure: Haha, do one.
Shure: 能咬吗
Shure: Can you bite it?
Tasha: 能咬能咬
Tasha: Yes, you can bite it.
Tasha: 展开再咬然后合上的
Tasha: Open it, bite, and then close it.
Shure: 好好我知道了
Shure: Okay, I got it.
Shure: 想起来了
Shure: I remember now.
Tasha: 哈
Tasha: Ha
Tasha: 哈哈太美了
Tasha: Haha, it's so beautiful.
Jake:美美
Jake: Beautiful, beautiful.
Shure: 射气吗
Shure: Are you releasing gas?
Jake:美美射
Jake: Beautifully releasing.
Shure: 够设吗或者这样
Shure: Is it enough, or like this?
Jake:多多少刚出院
Jake: Just a bit, just out of the hospital.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈好好好
Shure: Hahaha, okay, okay, okay.
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Jake:出院多久了
Jake: How long have you been out of the hospital?
Shure: 我们的麦克风
Shure: Our microphone.
Jake:我要干什么
Jake: What should I do?
Tasha: 把被子叠上
Tasha: Fold the quilt.
Jake:好
Jake: Okay.
Tasha: 行谢谢你
Tasha: Alright, thank you.
Shure: 7天第一次叠叠被子是吧
Shure: First time folding the quilt in 7 days, right?
Tasha: 谁7 你天天叠吗
Tasha: Who's 7? Do you fold it every day?
Shure: 我不点啊
Shure: I don't.
Tasha: 那不就行了
Tasha: Then it's fine.
Jake:那那也是七天
Jake: Then it's also 7 days.
Tasha: 把被子放这
Tasha: Put the quilt here.
Tasha: 是的呢
Tasha: Yes, indeed.
Shure: 谁放着海鸥的白噪音
Shure: Who's playing seagull white noise?
Shure: 我那拓展坞他妈放哪了
Shure: Where the hell did I put my docking station?
Tasha: 从哪掏的
Tasha: Where did you take it from?
其他人：那建议今天你表演
Others: Then I suggest you perform today.
其他人：你快来表演一个
Others: Come on, perform one.
其他人：匈牙利狂想曲
Others: Hungarian Rhapsody.
Jake:建议你们看看有没有火药杆
Jake: I suggest you check for gunpowder residue.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha
其他人：我已经串完了
Others: I've already skewered it all.
其他人：建议你现在点外卖啊
Others: I suggest you order takeout now.
Tasha: 两个串吗
Tasha: Two skewers?
Tasha: 两个串都串完了
Tasha: Both skewers are done.
其他人：哦还有他那个场
Others: Oh, there's still his scene.
其他人：没事马上我就去穿
Others: No worries, I'll go skewer it right away.
Tasha: 哇
Tasha: Wow.
Jake:哇那你点
Jake: Wow, then you decide.
Jake:你问他们想试什么
Jake: Ask them what they want to try.
其他人：我的评价是元记云饺
Others: My review is for Yuanji Yun Dumplings.
Jake:好行那你开吧
Jake: Okay, then go ahead.
其他人：不如吃米村拌饭
Others: How about having Micun Bibimbap?
Tasha: 我也觉得米村拌饭好吃
Tasha: I also think Micun Bibimbap is delicious.
其他人：米村拌饭是啥
Others: What's Micun Bibimbap?
其他人：你先搜一下
Others: Just search it first.
Tasha: 搜就知道了
Tasha: Just search and you'll know.
其他人：预制菜预制菜top one
Others: Pre-made dishes, pre-made dishes top one.
其他人：预制菜
Others: Pre-made dishes.
其他人：那我不要
Others: Then I don't want it.
Shure: 老北京就好这口
Shure: Old Beijing folks really like this stuff.
Shure: 预制菜你知道呵呵
Shure: Pre-made dishes, you know, haha.
其他人：他的预制菜就是比较健康一些
Others: His pre-made dishes are just healthier.
Jake:别的可是也是预制菜
Jake: But others are also pre-made dishes.
Jake:只是没告诉你自己
Jake: They just didn't tell you.
Tasha: 云记云饺也是预制菜
Tasha: Yunji Yun Dumplings are also pre-made dishes.
其他人：真的吗真的
Others: Really, really?
Tasha: 真的
Tasha: Really.
Tasha: 每天小车拉过来的
Tasha: Delivered by small carts daily.
Jake:那就就吃那个什么叫什么
Jake: Then let's just eat, what was it called?
Jake:白饭哈哈
Jake: Plain rice, haha.
Tasha: 米村拌饭
Tasha: Micun Bibimbap.
Jake:米村拌饭
Jake: Micun Bibimbap.
Jake:行
Jake: Alright.
其他人：OKOK
Others: OK, OK.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
其他人：这个还是不错
Others: This one is still good.
其他人：怎么这么远哎
Others: Why is it so far away, oh man.
其他人：你点这个
Others: You ordered this.
其他人：最远从领展购物广场送过来
Others: Delivered from the farthest Link Square.
Tasha: 套过
Tasha: Wrapped up.
Tasha: 套过你跟我说你不知道这样的封起来
Tasha: Wrapped up, you told me you didn't know it's sealed like this.
其他人：看时间看时间看时间
Others: Check the time, check the time, check the time.
Tasha: 你知道
Tasha: You know.
其他人：56分钟
Others: 56 minutes
其他人：可以吗
Others: Is that okay?
其他人：我不知道哎
Others: I don't know
其他人： 你上次点的是那个0展店吗
Others: Did you order from that zero-fee delivery place last time?
Jake:我我我这次
Jake: I, I, I did this time
Tasha: 就是那个10块钱配送费的
Tasha: The one with the 10 yuan delivery fee
Tasha: 就他
Tasha: Yeah, that one
其他人：那就他那就他
Others: Then let's go with that one
Tasha: 就他一件
Tasha: Just that one
其他人：你怎么那么熟练
Others: How come you are so familiar with this?
其他人：因为上次他们就吃的这个我觉得还可以
Others: Because they ordered this last time and I thought it was okay
其他人：好那我单独点个源记云饺
Others: Alright, then I'll order from Yuanji Yunjiao separately
Shure: 我觉得源记云饺会快我可以先吃上
Shure: I think Yuanji Yunjiao will be faster, I can eat first
其他人：这么饿
Others: So hungry
其他人：我不饿我不饿
Others: I'm not hungry, I'm not hungry
其他人：我还会我会最简单的
Others: I can only do the simplest
Jake:好听
Jake: Sounds good
Jake:牛逼虽然是这是啥呀
Jake: Amazing, although what is this?
Jake:这哈哈哈
Jake: This hahaha
Shure: 来我给大家
Shure: Let me show everyone
Jake:这啥呀哦嘿
Jake: What is this, oh hey
Shure: 表演一个
Shure: Perform something
Jake:行行行自创了是吧
Jake: Okay, did you create this yourself?
其他人：自创歌曲
Others: An original song
Jake:自创歌曲
Jake: An original song
其他人：几几个人
Others: How many people?
其他人：四五六七八九十个人
Others: Four, five, six, seven, eight, nine, ten people
Lucia: 哦这是巴赫
Lucia: Oh, this is Bach
Lucia: 的一个小步舞曲是吧
Lucia: A minuet, right?
Lucia: 好像是练完拜
Lucia: Seems like after practicing Bai
Lucia: 练完拜厄的第一首曲子就弹这个
Lucia: The first piece after practicing Bai's exercises is this
其他人：啊董叉叉也给你点吗
Others: Ah, is Jack ordering for you too?
其他人：你可以先点我想吃源记云饺
Others: You can order first, I want to eat Yuanji Yunjiao
Jake:挺好鼓手
Jake: Pretty good, drummer
Jake:咱就干鼓手的事情哈哈哈
Jake: Let's just do drummer stuff hahaha
其他人：个加四个这是十个人
Others: Four plus six, that's ten people
Shure: 怎么我鼓手怎么了
Shure: What's wrong with being a drummer?
其他人：这谁的这谁的手机
Others: Whose phone is this?
Shure: 鼓手还可以弹这个呢
Shure: Drummers can play this too
Jake:点完了
Jake: Done ordering
其他人：点完了
Others: Done ordering.
Shure: 怎么弹的
Shure: How did you play it?
Jake:好那就直接下单了
Jake: Alright, let's place the order.
其他人：10个人20块
Others: 10 people, 20 bucks.
其他人：呃200块钱
Others: Uh, 200 bucks.
其他人：我靠你好熟练
Others: Wow, you're so skilled.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
其他人：牛逼我来弹海阔天空试试
Others: Awesome, let me try playing "Boundless Oceans, Vast Skies".
其他人：这里的海洋风
Others: The ocean breeze here.
Lucia: 对但是我感觉这个
Lucia: Yeah, but I feel like this...
Lucia: 就是因为他本身是应该撕下来
Lucia: It's because it should be peeled off.
Lucia: 这些贴墙上的
Lucia: These are supposed to be stuck on the wall.
Lucia: 但我又害怕这些贴墙上会撕不下来
Lucia: But I'm worried they might not come off easily.
其他人：OK
Others: OK.
其他人：这回是OK
Others: This time it's OK.
Lucia: 所以大的那几个
Lucia: So the big ones...
Lucia: 我都是给他后面粘了胶带贴的
Lucia: I taped them on the back.
Lucia: 但是他不是有颜色吗
Lucia: But they're colored, right?
Jake:怎么多了100块钱
Jake: Why is there an extra 100 bucks?
Lucia: 就是本来应该透明
Lucia: They should be clear.
其他人：因为多了五个菜品
Others: Because we added five more dishes.
Lucia: 就是边上都是透明的
Lucia: The edges should be clear.
Lucia: 这样他就变白了然后就没那么好看了
Lucia: Now they're white and not as nice.
Tasha: 多了5个菜
Tasha: Added 5 more dishes.
Lucia: 救命
Lucia: Help!
其他人：就是现在是相当于一人一个菜
Others: So now it's like one dish per person.
Lucia: 我想先牺牲一点美观性
Lucia: I'm willing to sacrifice a bit of aesthetics.
其他人：然后98个菜
Others: And 98 dishes.
其他人：9个人8 哎
Others: 9 people, 8... hey.
其他人：9个 10个人8个菜
Others: 9... 10 people, 8 dishes.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Jake:来给您倒水
Jake: Let me pour you some water.
Tasha: 谢谢你
Tasha: Thank you.
其他人：我来一个
Others: Let me have a go.
其他人：我来一个等一下别人已经点歌了
Others: Let me have a go, wait, someone's already chosen a song.
Shure: 恰恰
Shure: Cha-cha.
Shure: 恰恰one恰
Shure: Cha-cha one cha.
Shure: two呲呲一
Shure: Two ts-ts one.
其他人：讲过了
Others: Mentioned it already.
其他人：讲啥
Others: Mention what?
Lucia: 虽然我房间有点乱
Lucia: Although my room is a bit messy
其他人：讲你不用给我买他本来也没给我买
Others: You don't need to buy it for me, he didn't get it for me either
其他人：我本来要给他买
Others: I was going to buy it for him
Shure: 切耶
Shure: Cut it out
其他人：这怎么弹妈不会了
Others: How do you play this, I can't anymore
Shure: 呀呀呀
Shure: Yeah yeah yeah
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 切one耶
Shure: Cut one, yeah
Shure: 特特呵呵
Shure: Te te haha
Shure: 稍等啊
Shure: Hold on a second
其他人：我的麦哎
Others: My mic, hey
其他人：卧槽
Others: Oh crap
Jake:这特效太高了
Jake: These effects are too high
其他人：我的麦很炸吗
Others: Is my mic too loud?
Shure: 喂喂喂耶
Shure: Hey hey hey yeah
Shure: yeah yeahyeah yeah
Shure: Yeah yeah yeah yeah
Shure: ladies and gentlemen
Shure: Ladies and gentlemen
Shure: now let's welcome to egolives world
Shure: Now let's welcome you to Egolives World
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome
其他人：味太臭了味太臭了
Others: The smell is too strong, the smell is too strong
Jake:牛逼
Jake: Awesome
Shure: today we will have a great and brain party
Shure: Today we will have a great and brainy party
Shure: it's called ego party
Shure: It's called Ego Party
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Jake:哈
Jake: Ha
Shure: 有
Shure: Yes
Shure: yeah
Shure: Yeah
Shure: （歌词）now i wanna two as fool around why the seems are
Shure: (Lyrics) Now I wanna fool around, why the scenes are
Shure: （歌词）小鹿乱撞
Shure: (Lyrics) Heart pounding
其他人：哎呦我操
Others: Oh my gosh
其他人：这个这个这个
Others: This this this
Jake:要不抓几个人下去打工吧
Jake: How about we grab a few people to work?
Jake:你们抓你们
Jake: You guys grab them
Jake:抓几个人
Jake: Grab a few people
Jake:你们
Jake: You guys
Jake:你下去打工吧
Jake: You go to work
Jake:要不下去收拾收拾
Jake: Or go down and tidy up
其他人：底下那个卡换了没
Others: Has the card below been changed?
Jake:都换了
Jake: All changed
Jake:但是你得收拾收拾
Jake: But you need to tidy up
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Shure: （歌词）很多大的笑脸
Shure: (lyrics) Many big smiles
Shure: （歌词）原谅我
Shure: (lyrics) Forgive me
Shure: （歌词）怀着冷眼与嘲笑
Shure: (lyrics) With cold eyes and ridicule
Shure: （歌词）怀着热闹的
Shure: (lyrics) With bustling
其他人：把我女朋友头挡住了
Other: You're blocking my girlfriend's head
Shure: （歌词）亲爱心
Shure: (lyrics) Dear heart
Shure: （歌词）一刹那接近
Shure: (lyrics) Close for a moment
Shure: （歌词）咚哒哒
Shure: (lyrics) Dong dada
Shure: （歌词）天空海阔的天真未变
Shure: (lyrics) The innocence of the vast sky and sea hasn't changed
Shure: （歌词）原谅我一生不羁放纵爱自由
Shure: (lyrics) Forgive me for living a life of unrestrained freedom
Shure: （歌词）也会怕有一天会跌倒oh no
Shure: (lyrics) But I'm also afraid that one day I might fall, oh no
Shure: （歌词）谁人都可以
Shure: (lyrics) Anyone can
其他人：这个麦
Other: This mic
Shure: 必然呀我还可以挂auto two
Shure: Sure, I can still add auto-tune
Alice:太优雅了
Alice: So elegant
Shure: 你知道吗
Shure: You know
其他人：换一首换一首换一首换一首
Other: Change the song, change the song, change the song, change the song
Shure: 呃
Shure: Uh
Alice:啊微微你咋样了
Alice: Ah Tasha, how are you?
Shure: yeah
Shure: Yeah
Alice:哇哦好可爱
Alice: Wow, so cute
Shure: 好OK
Shure: Alright, OK
Shure: 呀
Shure: Yeah
Shure: 我说句话
Shure: Let me say something
Shure: 他现在就会有点耶
Shure: He's going to be a bit like yeah
Shure: 哎不对
Shure: Oh wait
Shure: 不够等一下啊
Shure: Not enough, wait a second
Shure: 呃towarding scent yeah response
Shure: Uh, towarding scent, yeah, response
Shure: 给他调高一点
Shure: Turn it up a bit for him
Shure: （歌词）novembering i feel so lonely
Shure: (lyrics) Novembering, I feel so lonely
Shure: （歌词） so decided gonna be fine so
Shure: (lyrics) So decided gonna be fine so
其他人：修硕你来唱我来弹
Other: Shure, you sing, I'll play
Shure: 弹什么
Shure: Play what?
Shure: 唱什么
Shure: Sing what?
Alice:你看就是这个房间
Alice: Look, it's this room
Alice:需要我帮忙吗
Alice: Need my help?
Jake:好听呵呵呵
Jake: Sounds good, hehe
其他人：能不能跟着我的拍
Other: Can you follow my beat?
Shure: 你在唱什么呀
Shure: What are you singing?
其他人：重新开始啊
Others: Start over again.
Alice:Lucy啊你好了吗
Alice: Lucia, are you ready?
其他人：行吗修硕
Others: Are you ready, Shure?
Lucia: 快了快了
Lucia: Almost, almost.
Shure: 我不行
Shure: I can't do it.
其他人：你为什么不行
Others: Why can't you do it?
Lucia: 哈哈我快了快了
Lucia: Haha, almost there, almost there.
Alice:需要我帮你吗
Alice: Do you need my help?
Shure: 我就是不行
Shure: I just can't do it.
Jake:这些多理解啊
Jake: Try to understand this.
Alice:怎么还有头孢啊谁吃的头孢
Alice: Why is there still cephalosporin? Who's taking it?
其他人：不是党员吧
Others: Not a party member, right?
其他人：我不是
Others: I'm not.
其他人：OK你的文件和讲话
Others: OK, your documents and speech.
其他人：哈哈哈真的
Others: Haha, really.
Shure: 一赠品穿上送上
Shure: A gift, put it on and send it over.
其他人：我们我们
Others: We, we.
其他人：我们系的那个
Others: Our department.
其他人：对啊手敲了
Others: Yeah, typed by hand.
其他人：在word上手敲了
Others: Typed by hand in Word.
其他人：连GPT没用纯手写
Others: Without using GPT, purely handwritten.
其他人：可怪万一说错了呢
其他人：说错了说错了
其他人：我才有缺点呀
其他人：我是因为我理论学习不到位
Shure: 他要啥都说对
Shure: If he says everything right.
其他人：对啊我要啥都说对我就马克思了
其他人：我比他中国话好
Others: My Chinese is better than his.
Shure: 我们的志愿者先生
Shure: Our volunteer gentleman.
Alice:好热呀
Alice: It's so hot.
Shure: so hot
Shure: So hot.
Tasha: 是吗开空调
Tasha: Really? Turn on the air conditioner.
Shure: 可以
Shure: Sure.
Tasha: 鱼安康
Tasha: Ankang fish.
Alice:安康鱼
Alice: Anglerfish.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Alice:鱼康安
Alice: Fish Kang'an.
Shure: 这其实那俩字不发音就不就是安康
Shure: Actually, if you don't pronounce those two characters, it’s Ankang.
Shure: 那是鱼字旁
Shure: That's a fish radical.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello?
Shure: 呀
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello?
Shure: hello
Shure: Hello.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hello?
Shure: 呀
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 混响拉满
Shure: Max out the reverb.
Lucia: 那个鱼哎呀就不做了
Lucia: That fish, forget it.
Lucia: 我就直接把它放在那就行
Lucia: I'll just leave it there.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Okay.
Tasha: 变了没
Tasha: Has it changed?
Jake:就一串就行了是吧
Jake: Just one string is fine, right?
其他人：呃这样如果你想要
Others: Uh, like if you want to.
其他人：弹一首这个看看我还会吗
Others: Play a piece, let’s see if I still can.
Shure: 行
Shure: Alright.
其他人：这是有歌单吗还是你们弄的
Others: Is there a playlist or did you make it?
Katrina: 有个歌单
Katrina: There’s a playlist.
Shure: （歌词）什么能够给你
Shure: (Lyrics) What can I give you?
Shure: （歌词）爱你也需要
Shure: (Lyrics) Loving you also requires.
Shure: （歌词）很大的勇气
Shure: (Lyrics) A lot of courage.
Shure: （歌词）只怕我自己会爱上你
Shure: (Lyrics) I’m just afraid I might fall in love with you.
其他人：所以昨天后面你sftp
Others: So, yesterday, at the end, did you SFTP?
其他人：传过去了吗
Others: Did you transfer it?
Shure: 我放弃了
Shure: I gave up.
Shure: 昨天
Shure: Yesterday.
其他人：放弃了
Shure: 对啊我就
Shure: Yeah, I just.
Shure: 就说我干过他又能怎么样
Shure: I mean, I did it, so what?
其他人：OK
Others: OK
Shure: 反正我有购买记录了
Shure: Anyway, I have the purchase records.
Shure: 我有使用记录了
Shure: I have the usage records too.
Shure: 然后我做完
Shure: After I finished
Shure: 做完模型之后
Shure: making the model,
Shure: 我不能天天挂在那保存着吧
Shure: I couldn't just keep it hanging there every day, right?
Shure: 每天每小时烧3块钱
Shure: It costs 3 bucks an hour.
Shure: 然后我就销毁了
Shure: So, I destroyed it.
Shure: 人家也查不到
Shure: No one can check it.
其他人：销毁高级
Others: Destroying it is advanced.
Shure: 对啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 因为那服务器如果你不销毁的话
Shure: Because if you don't destroy the server,
Shure: 每小时扣我3块8毛钱
Shure: it deducts 3.80 an hour.
其他人：ok
Others: Ok.
Shure: 一天下来就多少钱呢
Shure: How much would that be in a day?
Shure: 3块844244*24
Shure: 3.80 * 24
Shure: 多少钱呢
Shure: How much is that?
Katrina: 你的房间装满了吗
Katrina: Is your room full yet?
Shure: 你要进来玩一玩吗
Shure: Do you want to come in and play?
Katrina: 你是在想我吗
Katrina: Are you thinking about me?
Katrina:  我就在想我要不要去装修我的房间
Katrina: I was just thinking if I should redecorate my room.
Katrina: 还是说把门一关
Katrina: Or just close the door.
Katrina: 反正他也不在里面找币
Katrina: Anyway, he's not in there looking for coins.
Shure: 稍微收拾一下
Shure: Tidy it up a bit.
Shure: 你可以用脸把碗洗了哈哈
Shure: You can use your face to wash the dishes, haha.
Alice:我们不需要先把它倒一波吗
Alice: Don't we need to empty it first?
Alice:下午不是还要录吗
Alice: We have to record in the afternoon, right?
Shure: 知道啊等康康说了再说吧
Shure: Yeah, let's wait for Kangkang to say something.
Shure: 康神
Shure: Kangkang.
其他人：康康
Others: Kangkang.
Shure: 你知道我说的是哪个康康吧
Shure: You know which Kangkang I'm talking about, right?
Shure: 呃no
Shure: Uh, no.
Shure: cnvirant
Shure: Cnvirant.
Shure: 你有玩瓦罗兰特吗
Shure: Do you play Valorant?
Shure: 那那个游戏里面
Shure: In that game,
Shure: 中国的有
Shure: the Chinese team,
Shure: EDG的瓦子里面有一个叫康康的
Shure: EDG's Valorant team has a guy called Kangkang.
Shure: 打狙很猛
Shure: He's great at sniping.
Shure: 大家叫他康神
Shure: Everyone calls him the Sniper God.
Alice:好但是现在12点半了
Alice: Okay, but it's already 12:30.
其他人：这么贵
Others: So expensive.
Jake:好残啊手
Jake: My hand is so tired.
Shure: 加油
Shure: Come on!
Alice:遥控器呢
Alice: Where's the remote?
Shure: 这是你的新的MacBook
Shure: This is your new MacBook.
Shure: 是吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 黑色的卧槽
Shure: It's black, whoa.
Shure: c黑色的
Shure: Yeah, it's black.
Shure: 人家是高高贵的黑色
Shure: It's a high-class black.
其他人：黑色的好看吗
Others: Does black look good?
其他人：什么黑色的
Others: What's black?
Shure: 就是他从M3开始才有黑色
Shure: They only started making it black from the M3.
其他人：等会我先把程序配一下
Others: Wait, let me set up the program first.
其他人：你别配啊刘帅买的黑色的
Others: Don't set it up, Choiszt bought a black one.
Katrina: 你那个用美纹胶粘的吗
Katrina: Did you use masking tape for that?
其他人：你看不
Others: Are you watching?
其他人：不看了
Others: Not watching.
其他人：卧槽还有这么屌的
Others: Whoa, this is so cool.
其他人：卧槽这联网这有问题
Others: Whoa, there's an issue with the connection.
其他人：这个会有那个切换输入法问题吗
Others: Will there be an issue with switching input methods?
Shure: 都有
Shure: There will be.
Shure: 只要是苹果就都
Shure: As long as it's Apple.
Shure: 怎么了
Shure: What's up?
Shure: 咋了啊
Shure: What happened?
Katrina: 好漂亮啊
Katrina: So beautiful.
Katrina: 我要去搞
Katrina: I want to do it.
Shure: 别搞你搞不出来的
Shure: Don't, you can't do it.
Katrina: 不放弃
Katrina: I won't give up.
Tasha: 下来吧额你要在上面勾吗
Tasha: Come down, are you going to hook up there?
Shure: 你可以把它平铺到这上面谢斌竹
Shure: You can lay it flat on this, Xie Binzhu.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Binzhu.
Shure: 单线程
Shure: Single-threaded.
Shure: 就脑子里面只有一个一个目标是吧
Shure: Only one goal in your mind, right?
其他人：脑子有俩一个钢琴一个
Others: Two things in mind, one piano, one...
Shure: 钢琴他都弹不好了
Shure: He can't even play the piano well.
Shure: 这心乱了
Shure: His mind is messed up.
其他人：无法休息
Others: Can't rest.
Shure: 当然可以啦
Shure: Of course, you can.
Jake:我贴这儿
Jake: I'll stick it here.
Jake:然后贴一排
Jake: Then stick a row of them.
Jake:你就几个呀
Jake: How many do you have?
Jake:how many
Jake: How many?
其他人：快弹高潮
Others: Play the climax part quickly.
Katrina: 你帮我把那风铃够了
Katrina: Can you help me get that wind chime?
Shure: 我动手能力不不行
Shure: I'm not good with hands-on stuff.
Shure: （歌词）直到不能呼吸
Shure: (Lyrics) Until I can't breathe
Shure: （歌词）为了你
Shure: (Lyrics) For you
Shure: （歌词）愿意
Shure: (Lyrics) Willing to
Shure: （歌词） 如果全世界
Shure: (Lyrics) If the whole world
Shure: 操按错音了对不起
Shure: Oops, hit the wrong note, sorry.
Shure: 还有个桥吗这
Shure: Is there another bridge here?
其他人：重新来啊
Others: Start over!
其他人： 好像那种公园就是大唱
Others: Feels like a big sing-along in the park.
Shure: （歌词）去珍惜而你在这里我总记得在哪里
Shure: (Lyrics) To cherish and you are here, I always remember where you are
Shure: （歌词）如果全世界我也可以忘记
Shure: (Lyrics) If I could forget the whole world
Shure: （歌词）至少还还有你值得我去珍惜
Shure: (Lyrics) At least there's still you worth cherishing
Shure: （歌词）你相信那是生命的奇迹
Shure: (Lyrics) Do you believe in the miracle of life?
Jake:你要不先插个电吧
Jake: Why don't you plug it in first?
其他人：哎你们那个电脑不是黑的吗
Others: Hey, isn't your computer black?
Shure: 我们都是深空灰的其实
Shure: Actually, ours are all Space Gray.
其他人：就是哪不一样这不一样
Others: But there's no difference, right?
Shure: 不是就是整个颜色就是不一样
Shure: No, the whole color is different.
Shure: 我们这是灰的
Shure: Ours is gray.
Shure: 你这是
Shure: Yours is...
其他人：我看是一样的
Others: I think it's the same.
Shure: 不一样你在光下面看就啊
Shure: It's different, look at it under the light.
Shure: 你看你放着对比一下这俩色
Shure: See, compare the two colors side by side.
Shure: 这是深空灰
Shure: This is Space Gray.
其他人：确实黑一点
Others: It does look a bit darker.
其他人：黑的好看
Others: Black looks nicer.
Shure: 确实显大气
Shure: It does look more premium.
Shure: 是吧
Shure: Right?
其他人：里边这个都是一样的
Others: The inside is all the same.
Shure: 对里面都是一样的
Shure: Yeah, the inside is the same.
Shure: 插口也是一样
Shure: The ports are the same too.
Shure: 我说插口也都是一样的
Shure: I mean, the ports are all the same.
其他人：哦对
Shure: 而且黑色的都显大感觉
Shure: And black always makes things look bigger.
其他人：那说明买对了
Other people: That means you bought the right one.
其他人： 肯定给我买黑的
Other people: Definitely bought the black one for me.
Shure: （歌词）自然总有一幅画
Shure: (lyrics) Nature always has a painting
Shure: （歌词）肩头的暴雨
Shure: (lyrics) The storm on the shoulder
Shure: （歌词）片刻后生成
Shure: (lyrics) Forms shortly after
Shure: （歌词）不屈的身体
Shure: (lyrics) An unyielding body
Jake:没人知道
Jake: Nobody knows.
Shure: （歌词）形影不离
Shure: (lyrics) Inseparable
Shure: （歌词）如果
Shure: (lyrics) If
Shure: （歌词）全世界我也可以放弃
Shure: (lyrics) I could give up the whole world
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello
其他人：坏了
Other people: Oh no
其他人：搞错了
Other people: Made a mistake
Jake:哎呦我操
Jake: Oh shit
其他人：我靠不是
Other people: Damn, no way
Shure: 要看什么
Shure: What are we looking at?
Shure: 红尘客栈
Shure: The Red Dust Inn
其他人：对这两个一模一样
Other people: Yeah, these two are exactly the same.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
其他人：修硕
Other people: Shure
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey
其他人：给我一个充电宝
Other people: Give me a power bank.
Shure: 你怎么要的东西这么多呢
Shure: Why do you need so many things?
Shure: 怎么野花
Shure: Why wildflowers
Shure: 家花哪有野花香是吗
Shure: Home flowers are not as fragrant as wildflowers, right?
其他人：傻逼因为这个有线
Other people: Dumbass, because this one has a cable.
Shure: OK
Shure: 懂了
Shure: Got it
其他人：哎呀我靠
Other people: Ah damn
Shure: 你给他端起来放这顶吧
Shure: You lift it up and put it on top.
Shure: 谢斌竹来来来
Shure: Xie Binzhu, come on.
Shure: 谢斌竹
Shure: Xie Binzhu
其他人：来了来了把它端上来
Other people: Coming, coming, lift it up.
Shure: 嗯
Shure: Mm-hmm
其他人：哎靖康
Other people: Hey, Jingkang
Jake:哎
Jake: Yeah
其他人：借个充电宝
Other people: Borrow a power bank.
Jake:没
Jake: Don't have one.
Jake:当然不能拔啊
Jake: Of course you can't unplug it.
其他人：她拿走了
Others: She took it away.
Jake:实在不能拿走
Jake: She really can't take it away.
Shure: 哎压着了压着了压着了
Shure: Oh, it's pressing down, it's pressing down, it's pressing down.
Tasha: 不能拿走不好意思这充摄像头的是吗
Tasha: Sorry, it can't be taken away. Is this for charging the camera?
其他人：对对对
Others: Yes, yes, yes.
Shure: 你瞅着点你瞅着点
Shure: Watch it, watch it.
Shure: 你底下看着点哥
Shure: Look down there, bro.
其他人：哎给我拿一下你那个平板把手机看不清他妈想死
Others: Hey, give me your tablet. I can't see with my phone, it's driving me crazy.
Tasha: 你的点充满了吗
Tasha: Is your battery full?
Shure: 嗯好
Shure: Yeah, okay.
Shure: 你的midi口在哪边
Shure: Where's your MIDI port?
其他人：在这边呢
Others: It's over here.
Shure: 卧槽咋这么远
Shure: Damn, why is it so far?
Shure: 这线好像不够长
Shure: This cable seems too short.
其他人：这是干啥的
Others: What's this for?
其他人：连电脑的吗
Others: To connect to the computer?
其他人：马上用斯坦福的钢琴给大家弹
Others: We'll use Stanford's piano to play for everyone soon.
Tasha: 斯坦福
Tasha: Stanford?
其他人：必须的 800万
Others: Of course, 8 million.
Tasha: 不是斯坦威吗
Tasha: Isn't it Steinway?
Shure: 斯坦威
Shure: Steinway.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahahahaha.
Jake:完了完了完了完了都录上了
Jake: Oh no, it's all recorded.
Shure: 露怯了
Shure: Exposed.
Jake:完了都录上了
Jake: Oh no, it's all recorded.
其他人：都录上了吧
Others: It's all recorded, right?
Tasha: 杨老板
Tasha: Jake.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:what should i do
Jake: What should I do?
Jake:哎哟好看
Jake: Oh, it looks good.
Jake:我的这个在哪儿啊
Jake: Where's mine?
其他人：你连上了是吧
Others: Are you connected?
Shure: 连上了
Shure: Connected.
其他人：那我把我这声音关了
Others: Then I'll mute my sound.
Shure: 来吧用
Shure: Go ahead and use it.
其他人：我操
Others: Oh my god.
Shure: 哼哼好
Shure: Hmm, good.
其他人：啊
Others: Ah.
其他人：能吃真的
Others: Can we really eat it?
其他人：为啥问问能不能吃啊
Others: Why ask if we can eat it?
Shure: 呵呵呵你别一脸高潮的样子好吗
Shure: Hehe, can you not look so ecstatic?
Jake:批准了
Jake: Approved.
其他人：这个你吃吗
Others: Are you eating this?
Jake:这我不吃
Jake: I won't eat this.
Jake:吃不动了
Jake: I can't eat anymore.
Jake:今天要吃很多的你知道吗
Jake: You know, we have to eat a lot today.
Jake:啊今天要吃很多的
Jake: Yeah, we have to eat a lot today.
其他人：为什么
Others: Why?
Jake:因为要做很多
Jake: Because we need to do a lot.
其他人：今天还要做啊少做点
Others: We still need to do it today? Do less.
Shure: 你好
Shure: Hello.
其他人：你怎么又下来了
Others: Why did you come down again?
Shure: 我是一个
Shure: I'm a...
其他人：游荡之人
Others: Wanderer.
Shure: yes
Shure: Yes.
其他人：快我的外卖到了
Others: Hurry, my delivery is here.
其他人：饭到了吗
Others: Has the food arrived?
Jake:没有
Jake: No.
Jake:没有一点办法
Jake: There's no way.
Lucia: 没有一点办法
Lucia: There's no way.
Shure: （歌词）没有一点点防备也没有一丝顾虑
Shure: (lyrics) Without any preparation, without any hesitation.
Jake:你要干嘛
Jake: What are you doing?
Jake:马上马上很快很快
Jake: Soon, soon, very soon.
Shure: 垫个垫应该更高一点哎
Shure: If I put a cushion, it should be higher.
其他人：就给我屁股垫确实
Others: Just put a cushion under my butt, indeed.
其他人：要不然弹的太
Others: Otherwise, the bounce is too...
其他人：卧槽
Others: Whoa.
Shure: 又舒服了
Shure: Much more comfortable now.
Shure: 斯坦福你弹的是斯坦福钢琴
Shure: Stanford, you're playing a Stanford piano.
Jake:就凭这句话你就得有一只offer
Jake: Just for saying that, you should get an offer.
Jake:录下来了
Jake: I recorded it.
Jake:我去
Jake: Oh man.
Jake:你怎么这么多东西
Jake: Why do you have so much stuff?
Shure: 终于想起来我是下来取啥的
Shure: Finally remembered what I came down to get.
Shure: 呵自己点自己的是吗中午
Shure: Hah, you ordered your own food, right? Noon.
其他人：没有没有刚点
Others: No, just ordered it.
其他人：但我今天中午特别想吃这个
Others: But I really wanted to eat this for lunch today.
其他人：我就点了这个哦
Others: So I ordered this.
其他人：那你肯定是听不出来我他妈都弹不出来
Others: Then you definitely can't tell, I can't even play it.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 我下去三趟其实都是要拿平板
Shure: I went down three times, all to get the tablet.
Shure: 但我都忘拿上去了
Shure: But I forgot to bring it up each time.
Shure: 你是不是要这个
Shure: Is this what you need?
其他人：这个不会弹了
Others: I can't play this.
其他人：啊放个平板就会了是吧
Others: Ah, with a tablet you can play it, huh?
其他人：我靠全生了2年没弹了
Others: Wow, it's been two years since I played.
其他人：我来练一下
Others: Let me practice a bit.
其他人：我你妈搞这么大
Others: Damn, you set up so much.
其他人：还好这个不会弹了
Others: Luckily, this one doesn't bounce.
其他人：搞点简单的吧
Others: Let's do something simple.
Shure: 好像有阅读模式吧
Shure: Seems like there's a reading mode.
其他人：有用吗
Others: Is it useful?
Shure: 啊没有显示阅读器
Shure: Uh, there's no reader display.
Shure: 你可以把他这单独放大这样
Shure: You can enlarge it separately like this.
其他人：OK这够了这够了
Others: OK, this is enough, this is enough.
其他人： na na na na na na
Others: na na na na na na
其他人：你为什么要折磨自己
Others: Why are you torturing yourself?
Jake:好看
Jake: It looks good.
其他人：听点流行乐吧
Others: Let's listen to some pop music.
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure.
Shure: 空调遥控器在哪呢
Shure: Where's the air conditioner remote?
Jake:你可以开了
Jake: You can turn it on.
Jake:收拾完可以开了
Jake: After cleaning, you can turn it on.
Jake:来
Jake: Come on.
其他人：耶
Others: Yay.
Shure: 我们是不是收拾完之后一起做蛋糕了
Shure: Should we make a cake together after we finish cleaning?
Jake:吃完之后吃饭
Jake: After eating, we can have dinner.
Jake:做蛋糕差不多对就结了
Jake: Making a cake, about right, then we're done.
Jake:是吧把这把
Jake: Right, let's do this.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:这可能摆摆摆
Jake: Maybe just arrange it.
Shure: 稍微摆摆
Shure: Arrange it a bit.
Jake:椅子稍微摆摆
Jake: Arrange the chairs a bit.
其他人：这是哪是
Others: Where is this?
Jake:喂
Jake: Hello.
Jake:哎好好好好好好
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure: 加油
Shure: Good luck.
其他人：现在这么高级现在显示的都可以改
Others: It's so advanced now, you can change the display.
其他人：什么显示我你妈
Others: What display, you...
Shure: 呵呵
Shure: Haha.